dernière étape du chantier de rénovation
de la gare de trappes jusqu'à la fin de
la semaine une quinzaine de techniciens
interviennent deux nuits afin de
procéder à la pose du toit
une opération rendue délicate par la
présence à proximité des lignes à haute
tension monte de 3 mètres séparent la
nouvelle structure des caténaires une
coupure de courant est donc programmée
chaque soir pendant deux semaines afin
d'éviter tout risque
alors je vous parle c'est le dernier
train
ces derniers trains qui rentrent en gare
donc nous on a la chance et c'est
important pour nous il est 23 heures 40
il est à l'heure
et quand ce train aura quitté la zone la
zone de cette voie là derrière on pourra
commencer les procédures
donc je suis là pour prendre la
conciliation caténaires parce qu'il ya
1500 volts en courant continu qui passe
et dès que l'entreprise juge argent
risque d'entrer en contact
faux comment prendre la conciliation
couper le courant survenue à partir à
émettre à la terre un contact avec le
central situé à montparnasse est assurée
tous les mouvements sur les lignes de
train ils sont consignés là je vais
aller prier pour ouvrir le sectionneur
quant aux ça permet de couper le courant
à partir de cet appareil que la
chanteuse au delà la procédure faut
mettre une plaque et une fois la poignée
tirer reste à poser les perches pour
assurer cette fameuse mise à la terre
qui pourra dériver le courant s'il
venait à être rétablie par erreur les
poutres peuvent maintenant être posée à
5 mètres de hauteur
en moins de quatre heures là il continue
de poser les consoles ensuite ils vous
continuez à poser les rives la
couverture et cetera croit alors
peut-être pas tout dans la nuit parce
qu'effectivement la coupure est très
très petit donc après ils ont encore
quatre nuls la semaine prochaine pour
terminer toutes ces parties là réseau
ferré de france et sncf interviennent de
concert sur ce chantier de 864 1000
euros
les délais sont pour l'instant respecté
inauguration prévue en novembre